hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live die Diskussion nach den
Ausschreitungen in der Silvesternacht
die hält an konsequenteres durchgreifen
und härtere Strafen für Gewalttäter das
fordern die einen denn für Gewalttäter
die wie hier in der Silvesternacht
randaliert und Einsatzkräfte angegriffen
haben das steht in der Diskussion aber
auch eine Debatte über soziale Teilhabe
und Integrationen diese wollen andere
führen das sind keine neuen Themen aber
sie sind neu angestachelt vor allem seit
die Berliner Polizei Details zu den
Verdächtigen bekannt gegeben hat demnach
wurden 145 Menschen vorläufig
festgenommen sind aber erstmal wieder
auf freiem Fuß und zu den Details zählt
auch dass darunter 45 Menschen mit
deutschen Pass war waren 27 Verdächtige
mit afghanischer Nationalität und 21
Syrer
dass die Diskussionen die jetzt in
Teilen geführt wird nun auf die
ethnische Herkunft heruntergebrochen
wird das führt weg von den eigentlichen
Problemen sagen Menschen die sich in der
Community auskennen die Frage heute bei
uns muss der Staat Hertha durchgreifen
und ihr könnt gerne mitdiskutieren es
ist viel Stoff zum Reden schreibt direkt
in den Stream oder schickt auch gerne
eure Fragen per Mail ganz wie ihr
möchtet und wir können sprechen im
zweiten Teil der Sendung mit dem
Berliner Sozialarbeiter Burak aber jetzt
am Anfang sprechen wir zunächst mit dem
Jugendrichter aus Berlin mit Andreas
Müller seit 1994 macht er den Job und er
verlangt ein härteres Durchgreifen bei
jugendlichen Straftätern guten Abend
Herr Müller
guten Abend Frau jung es ist nicht ganz
richtig wie sie einen moderiert haben
ein härteres Durchgreifen verlange ich
erstmal per se nicht wenn es notwendig
wird dann ja was ich verlange ist dass
wir sich eine schon seit 20 Jahren
verlange ein schnelles Agieren der
Strafverfolgungsbehörden weil das ist
zunächst einmal die beste Prävention und
darüber hinaus auch für die Täter
wichtig damit sie nicht wieder in
Erscheinung treten
und ist das derzeit so dass eben nicht
schnell nicht konsequent genug
durchgegriffen wird bei jugendlichen
Straftätern
das kann man so auch nicht sagen wir
haben solche Exzesse ja in den
vergangenen Jahren immer wieder gehabt
ich erinnere an diese westernacht von
Köln ich erinnere an die Problematik in
Stuttgart auch da sind junge Leute auf
die Straße gegangen haben dann sich mit
der Polizei
herumgeschlagen haben Straftaten
begangen haben Verstöße hier und da
gegen der Strafgesetzbuch begangen wir
haben wir haben also kein absolut neues
Phänomen also ein besonders seltenes
Ereignis wir haben was was wir immer
wieder haben und wir haben immer wieder
die gleiche Diskussion es geht mir auch
nicht darum ob die Täter jetzt Deutsch
sind ob Sie aus irgendwelchen Ländern
dieser Welt kommen sondern es geht mir
darum dass in Zukunft mal hingeschaut
wird dass man diese Leute
möglichst schnell vor die Richter
bekommt den kann man auch analysieren
welche Wut dazu gebracht hat so zu
agieren man muss gegebenenfalls auch mal
harter Hand rangehen damit es eine
Abschreckung für die Leute ist ist die
bisher noch nicht in Erscheinung
getreten sind und das geht nur durch
schnelles und effektives Arbeiten der
Justiz insbesondere der
Staatsanwaltschaft und dann gehören die
Sachen ganz schnell auf die
richtertische wir haben eben gerade
gesehen als sie geantwortet haben es gab
eben auch 2020 Vorfälle die uns in
Erinnerung geblieben sind aus Stuttgart
also absolut richtig kein Berliner
sondern ein deutschlandweites Problem
aber gehen wir jetzt noch mal auf die
Silvesternacht auf Berlin ein denn das
ist ja auch jetzt sehr in der der
öffentlichen Debatte wie sehen sie also
wie sehr sehen sie deine Chancen dass
jetzt die 145 Verdächtigen dass es da
dann aber auch zu konsequenten schnellen
vielleicht urteilen wenn nötig kommt
die sehe ich sehr wohl man hat ja die
Personalien dieser Person da sie in
Gewahrsam genommen wurde nach meiner
Kenntnis gibt es noch viel viel mehr
Ermittlungsverfahren ja dann muss man
schauen wie es die Beweislage und die
Beweislage wird in Einzelfällen relativ
gut sein weil man hör Video Aufzeichnung
hat weil man
Aufzeichnungen der Polizeibeamter hat
weil man auch zeugen von der Polizei
benutzen kann oder sonstige ja und dann
gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten
schnell zu agieren unser Gesetz hat
alles einmal im Jugendstrafrecht der
sogenannte Antragsverfahren da kann man
relativ schnell agieren das ist
ehemalige Neuköllner Modell was leider
Gottes verloren gegangen ist Ermittlung
der Polizei
abstaatsanwaltschaft von der
Staatsanwaltschaft zum Gericht man
kümmert sich um solche Sachen immer nur
wenn es Exzesse gibt die Politiker die
heute einmal gehen sind und wiederum
nach nach schärfen Gesetzen rufen waren
jahrelang schon in der Lage solche
Strukturen aufzubauen aber wir nehmen an
es sind nicht alle jugendlich sondern
darüber hinaus gibt es auch
heranwachsene also Leute ab 18 da können
Sie das beschleunigte Verfahren wählen
Sie können Anwälte bestellen und können
bis zu einem Jahr verhängen und wenn es
ganz schlimme Straftaten sind dann kann
wenn die staatsgeweit nämlich die
Staatsanwaltschaft vernünftig schnell
und gut ausgestattet agiert auch hier
ein schnelles Verfahren herbeigeführt
werden und das ist die beste Prävention
für die Zukunft wir haben einen User er
nennt sich myself der fragt bei Youtube
warum werden alle Jugendlichen
eigentlich immer wieder auf freien Fuß
gesetzt genau das löst diese grenzenlose
Respektlosigkeit aus meint der User
das kann ich ihnen einfach sagen
zunächst wird in allen Fällen die
Staatsanwaltschaft gar keinen Antrag bei
den Richtern gestellt haben weil
möglicherweise die Straftat zu gering
ist die Beweise nicht ausreichen oder
aber das dürfte mit entscheidend sein
weil keine Haftgründe vorliegen
Haftgründe sind Fluchtgefahr
Wiederholungsgefahr oder
Verdunklungsgefahr Fluchtgefahr in aller
Regel sowieso nicht und das ist
natürlich auch abhängig davon was den
Täter zu erwarten was der Täter zu
erwarten hat das ist es sind normale
Regeln der Strafprozessordnung die
gelten für alle die haben immer golden
und die sind auch vernünftig man sollte
jetzt nicht alle sofort in den Knast
packen nur weil sie vor Ort gewesen sind
sondern nur die die es tatsächlich
verdient haben und wo dieser Haftgründe
vorliegen
sie hatten in ihrer vorherigen Antwort
das will ich nur kurz vorneweg geben
noch das sogenannte Neuköllner Modell
angesprochen darauf kommen wir auch
gleich noch zu sprechen wollen aber erst
noch mal in einen Beitrag schauen von
meiner Kollegin Henriette de Maizière
die hat sich noch mal auf die Suche
gemacht in Berlin in Neukölln also ein
Zentrum der Ausschreitung in der
Silvesternacht nach Antworten wir
schauen zusammen in den Beitrag und
sprechen dann weiter
Berlin Neukölln steht für Multikulti
knapp die Hälfte der hier lebenden
Menschen hat eine Migrationsgeschichte
nach der Silvesternacht ist der Bezirk
wieder einmal in die Schlagzeilen
gekommen hier auf der Sonnenallee in
Berlin-Neukölln müssen sich verstörende
Szenen abgespielt haben in der Silvester
Nacht hinter uns sein ausgebrannter Bus
hier ist das Feiern komplett eskaliert
im Gewalt fast ausschließlich junge
Männer bereit Silvester Böller und
Raketen als Waffen einzusetzen auch
gegen polizei und Rettungskräfte Gewalt
in bisher kaum bekanntem Ausmaß wir
fragen nach ja war gut aber bisschen
Probleme weißt du Leute bisschen
aggressiv mit dieser Rakete dieser Satz
das war alles aber war schön wir treffen
aber auch Menschen die hier leben die
das anders sehen hatten sie Angst ja
es war so laut es war unangenehm es ist
immer noch dass es da oder drüben hier
Böller
es war nicht schön also als ich heute
morgen den nächsten Tag der Bus gesehen
habe war richtig entsetzt
auch gesagt dass das geht zu weit
zugreifen und weil wie Sie wissen die
Jugendliche die haben auch die Grenzen
verloren die Polizei ermittelt gegen die
Straftäter der Nacht ein ganzer
kiezgerät in Verruf durch einzelne und
die ewige Frage ist die Integration
gescheitert man kann mit Sicherheit
davon ausgehen dass keiner von denen das
irgendwie großartig geschafft hat bisher
irgendwo anzukommen also die kriegen
ihre Anerkennung in ihrer Gruppe und
solange ihn das reicht verpassen Sie
auch alles andere was eigentlich wichtig
wäre fürs Leben die krawaller der
Silvester Nacht sind nicht nur ein
Berliner Problem es braucht eine
bundesweite Antwort
bundesweite Antwort aber auch
bundesweite Diskussion insbesondere von
der politisch rechten Seite wird eine
Debatte über die ethnische Herkunft
geführt was spielt das für eine Rolle
würden Sie sagen
für mich persönlich spielt es überhaupt
keine Rolle das sind Menschen die sind
hier es sind Menschen die hier geboren
sind es sind Menschen die die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit haben und es sind
einfach junge Leute so und die ethische
Geschichte natürlich in so einem Rolle
weil sie eben da wohnen weil sie sich
dort aufhalten weil sie dort lieber
leben das ist das einzige aber deswegen
jetzt anders zu agieren als ob es in
deutsche Zeltplatz wäre wo irgendwelche
Skinheads durchdrehen tut mir leid das
spielt keine Rolle es spielt natürlich
eine Rolle
ob diese jungsperspektive haben
Perspektive ist unheimlich wichtig dazu
kann ich aber im Moment gar nicht sagen
weil da müsste man eine Analyse machen
wer hat da eigentlich agiert wer hat da
eigentlich genau Straftaten begangen
sind es Leute die keine Lehrer haben
sind es Leute die nicht arbeiten dürfen
sind es vielleicht ja ganz normale
Lehrling um der Ecke das wissen wir
alles noch nicht aber wenn man das
wüsste dann könnte man sicherlich sagen
ja die Perspektivlosigkeit bei diesen
jungen Menschen führt auch zu dieser
nicht nachvollziehbaren Gewalt und er
nicht nachvollziehbaren Wut auf Polizei
und Feuerwehr Behörden
auch in unserem Stream gibt es Fragen
die in die Richtung gehen deswegen
möchte ich noch mal hier nachfragen User
Userin metella möchte wissen Herr Müller
warum gab es solche Vorfälle an
Silvester in dem Maß erst seit 2015 also
eine Annahme und denken Sie nicht dass
die unkontrollierte Zuwanderung aus dem
Ausland damit zu tun hat
also ich kann einfach mal sagen also ich
bin ja 30 Jahre Jugendlicher
das ist nicht nur 30 Jahre
jugendgerichtet bin ja auch schon 61
Jahre Menschen in dieser Gesellschaft
ich habe in Kreuzberg gewohnt in der
Neukölln geworden ich habe politische
Demonstrationen mitbekommen ich habe
andere Übergriffe auch von ganz normalen
deutschen mitbekommen die in den
vergangenen Jahren stattgefunden haben
wir erinnern uns auch an Gewalt von
rechtsradikalien in Rostock Lichtenhagen
all das ist passiert und im Moment haben
wir eben junge Menschen ja die
ein bisschen anders aussehen aber das
ist mit der mit der
quasi das reinlassens in unsere
Gesellschaft was zu tun haben ist nicht
so ich selber habe nach wie vor als
jugendlichter überwiegen deutsche junge
Männer die Scheiße bauen ja ich habe
aber auch Leute die über im Jahre 2015
nach Deutschland gekommen sind die
machen zweimal Scheiße genau wie andere
ich habe aber auch ein ganz ganz paar
wenige wo ich richtig hart rangegangen
sind und einige davon wurden später auch
abgeschoben aber es sind Einzelfälle und
das muss man sehen und da muss die
Justiz natürlich hart rangehen aber
jetzt generell zu sagen alle jungen
Männer die da gekommen sind sind
potentielle Straftäter ist nicht richtig
schauen wir noch mal einen Blick auf die
Strafen also ein Problem aus Sicht des
Psychologen am Mattmann zur ist Gewalt
gegen Polizisten gilt bei vielen vielen
Jugendlichen als legitim und er sieht
hier insbesondere auch ein Problem bei
der Bestrafung von Jugendlichen in
Berlin wir haben einen Ton dazu hören
mal kurz zusammen rein
ich bin sehr oft unterwegs auch in
Gefängnissen und ich habe das Gefühl vor
allem in Berlin haben die Jugendliche
das Gefühl sie haben Freischein sie
können alles machen ich treffe immer
wieder auf Jugendlicher in anderen
Gefängnis in anderen Bundesländern die
sagen mein Fehler war dass ich nicht in
Berlin sozusagen
inhaftiert wurde da muss Berlin
natürlich auch die
Rechtsstaat die schon existiert also
brauchen keine neue Gesetze einfach
durchsetzen und Botschaften vermitteln
das Angriffe auf Polizisten keine
Sache die man einfach tolerieren darf in
diesem Land
würden sie das so unterschreiben dass
das also auch in berlin-spezifisches
Problem zum Teil ist
ich kenne das Interview nicht an meinen
Sour und auch seine Arbeit aber er muss
auch genau hin gucken warum ist das so
ja warum weil nämlich im vielen
Bereichen im Jugendstrafrecht angewandt
wird und das schlimme daran ist nicht
das später auf irgendwelchen aus
irgendwelchen Gründen vielleicht hier
und da auch mal milde beurteilt wird das
schlimme ist das viel zu spät geteilt
wird und da muss angesetzt werden die
müssen posten und wer einmal Widerstand
gegen die staatsgewaltschaft
Staatsgewalt leistet gehört nicht sofort
ja in den Knast sondern den muss auch
eine Chance gegeben werden es sei denn
es ist ein knallharter Widerstand aber
wenn Sie regelmäßig sofort verfolgt
würden diese jungen Menschen dann würde
ihn klar gemacht werden beim nächsten
Mal ist einmal zu viel und dann landest
du im Knast und jetzt was machst du dies
oder jenes oder gehst vier Wochen in
Arrest ja so einfach ist er sich habe
viele junge Menschen die auch Widerstand
geleistet haben deutsche ja auch Leute
die keinen deutschen Nationalpass haben
ja und die den tut es anschließend
unheimlich leid was sie gemacht haben
manchen eben nicht und wenn wem es nicht
leid tut der hat dann auch harte
Konsequenzen zu
zu erleiden und da gebe ich ihm insoweit
Recht manchmal müsste ein bisschen
härter gehandelt werden aber man kann
das nicht üben kann Scheren unmittelbar
und konsequent ja vergessen ja
ich habe nur eins vergessen wir haben
jetzt 20 17 schon die Strafvorschriften
verschärft all das hat nichts gebracht
ich bleibe dabei schnelles agieren ja
schnelles agieren ist wesentlich besser
als permanente Forderung von Haft Haft
dann wenn es sich um Wiederholungstäter
handelt wenn es Leute sind die
wiederholt in Erscheinung getreten sind
gehen wir zum Schluss noch mal auf eine
Sache ein sie ja
aber gerne
prima wir hören uns wieder gehen wir zum
Schluss noch mal auf eine Sache ein die
wir am Anfang schon kurz angesprochen
hatten also wir haben verstanden
unmittelbar schnell direkte Konsequenz
und auch im konsequent aber kommen wir
noch mal drauf zu sprechen versprechen
sie fordern seit Jahren schon das
sogenannte Neuköllner Modell das haben
sie mit entwickelt das sollte dazu
führen dass eben bei Jugendlichen Straf-
und Intensivtätern die Strafe auf dem
Fuße folgt auch die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin Giffey ändert jetzt
daran und der Bezirksbürgermeister von
Neukölln sagte dass das sagte jetzt
aktuell dass das sogenannte Neuköllner
Modell nicht mehr so häufig angewendet
wird wie vor Jahren wie kann das sein
warum ist das ein bisschen in der
Schublade verschwunden an dieser Stelle
an dieser Stelle wüsste ich jetzt
eigentlich emotional wütend werden genau
auf diese Person das sind ja teilweise
Weggefährten von Kirsten Heisig ja die
in den Jahren vor 2010 sich dieses
Neuköllner Modell Erd hat und dieses
bundesweit vorantreiben wollte und dann
hat die Berliner Politik sowohl
cdu-senatoren die jetzt mehr Haft
fordern oder sonst was als auch
spd-senatoren oder grüne Senatoren die
haben das nicht weiter vorangetrieben
und das ist in den Schubladen
verschwunden auch in anderen
Bundesländern und immer wenn es zu
irgendeinem Access kommt ja dann wird
das erneut gefordert und so weiter nun
sind diese Menschen ja in politischen
Positionen wo sie es machen könnten und
zwar gerichtet auf die Zukunft aber es
wird gleichfalls in einer Woche wieder
vergessen sein weil man nicht diese
runden Tische macht nämlich ohne Tische
Polizei Justiz Staatsanwaltschaft
Richter das sind die runden Tische die
gebraucht werden und nicht einen
generell herunter Tisch wo 50 Leute sich
alle zehn Minuten irgendwie abwechseln
in verschiedenen Geschichten also ich
ich bin wütend ich bin eigentlich in den
letzten Tagen jetzt werde ich gerade
wütend ja in den letzten Tagen wenn ich
das so alles immer wieder höre das höre
ich seit 30 Jahren die Härte wie die
gefordert wird und die Ausländer sind
schuld und wir wir müssen mehr
Sozialarbeit und dies und jenes was
strafrechtlich wichtig ist wird gar
nicht gemacht oder in den Schubladen
vergessen so einfach was soll ich jetzt
noch sagen jetzt fällt mir gerade gar
nichts mehr ein auf wenn ich schimpfen
kann ich kann ja einen Rundumschlag
machen die sollen sich wirklich mal
hinsetzen die Justizminister hier
Innenminister auf Bundesebene und auf
landeseben und fragen wie schaffen wir
es dass junge Menschen Männer auch ja
gar nicht erst zu intensiv Tätern werden
und das schaffen wir indem sie relativ
schnell ein vor dem Buch geknallt wird
bekommen und nicht erst nach einem Jahr
oder anderthalb Jahren ist hoffentlich
hier und da weitere Straftaten an wie
sie lachen sich langsam aber sicher über
den deutschen Rechtsstaat Tod so wir
haben einen O-Ton von Franziska giffert
die hat sich bei uns im Mittagsmagazin
geäußert lassen sie uns zum ganz zum
Schluss noch mal kurz zusammen reinhören
Franziska Giffey bei uns im
Mittagsmagazin
also ich kann mich erinnern an meine
Zeit in Neukölln wir haben dort das
Neuköllner Modell umgesetzt mit der
Jugendgerichtshilfe und der
Jugendgerichtsbarkeit die eben das predo
hatte Strafverfolgung muss auf dem Fuß
verfolgen zusammen mit der
Jugendsozialarbeit mit der
Integrationsarbeit vor Ort das müssen
wir wieder verstärkt machen und das
heißt auch die Gerichtsbarkeit die
Jugend Richter haben eine Verantwortung
hier in schnelle Strafverfahren zu
kommen darüber werden wir auch nächste
Woche im Senat beraten denn die Straßen
Möglichkeiten die gibt es es muss zügig
umgesetzt werden
zusätzlich möchte Franziska Giffey ein
Gipfel gegen Jugendgewalt abhalten zum
Schluss die Antwort von Ihnen bringt das
was
der Gipfel gegen Jugendgewalt sie soll
erst mal das umsetzen was seit 10 Uhr 12
Jahren gefordert wird sie sind doch an
der Macht ja sie hätten das schon lange
machen können die SPD und die CDU ich
habe das auch in verschiedenen
Interviews auch im Zusammenhang mit
Kirsten Heisig immer wieder gesagt habe
gesagt ihr müsst das in die Gänge
kriegen die Jugend Richter in Berlin
Tiergarten wollen ja aber Sie müssen
sich erstmal hinsetzen und nicht
Strukturen schaffen die Polizei muss
ermitteln ganz ganz schnell und da muss
politischer Druck hinter uns dieser
politische Druck darf nicht kurz vor der
Wahl kommen er muss vorbereiten für das
nächste Silvesterfest gemacht werden und
das ist ja Punkt und was mich auch
aufregt egal ob es hier die CDU ist oder
die SPD oder sonst was im halben Jahr
hat man es wieder vergessen bis zur
nächsten Krawall macht gerade Weihnacht
egal von wem die jetzt kommt vielleicht
kommt ja von Hertha Fans oder sonstigen
ja auch da musst du agiert werden
sagt Jugend Richter Andreas Müller aus
Berlin herzlichen Dank dass Sie bei uns
zu Gast waren
ich bedanke mich für die Einladung auch
wenn es mir wieder ein paar Emotionen
gekostet hat tschüss Frau jung das ist
in Ordnung emotional darf man bei dem
Thema auch werden sprechen wir nun also
über folgendes in Berlin das ist
vielleicht auch wichtig mal zur Info
haben 1,4 Millionen Menschen einen
sogenannten Migrationshintergrund das
sind 38 Prozent der Bevölkerung dort man
tue dieser Gruppe Unrecht wenn wir sie
in Gänze stigmatisiert und
stigmatisieren und kriminalisieren das
sagt die Berliner integrations- und
migrationsbeauftragte es gehe um
abgehängte Jugendliche nötig sei also
ich zitiere noch mal eine Debatte
darüber wie eine bildungssozial und
Arbeitsmarktpolitik aussehen muss die
auf eine Migrationsgesellschaft
ausgerichtet ist und darüber können wir
jetzt sprechen mit dem Berliner
Sozialarbeiter und Streetworker murak
der täglich mit Jugendlichen arbeitet
schönen guten Abend
guten Abend hi
Herr tschanneberg direkt zum Anfang mal
die Frage wir haben so viel schon gehört
was in dieser Debatte von so vielen
Seiten jetzt plötzlich diskutiert wird
worüber sollte denn aus ihrer Sicht
gesprochen werden
naja weiß ich nicht ob schnellere
Strafverfolgung das beste präventive
oder ein gutes präventives Mittel ist um
über all diese
ja um das ganze Gespräch zu vertiefen
ich glaube dass wir vorher ansetzen
müssen weil wir bewegen uns ständig in
den Bereich dass wir gucken die Symptome
zu bekämpfen und darüber haben wir schon
im ganz ganz vielen Debatten gesprochen
aber wir lenken unsere Aufmerksamkeit
selten auf die Ursachen ja und die
Ursachen da der Richter schon ähm
interessante Aspekte angesprochen er
sprach von Chancengleichheit er sprach
von Rassismus und äh also solchen Dingen
auch ein Teil aber auch ein politischer
Teil habe ähm dementsprechend weiß ich
nicht ob es reicht wenn wir ständig nur
über Strafverfolgung härtere Gesetze
schnellere Gesetze etc sprechen
ich möchte dazu einen Kommentar aus der
Community Vorlesen bei YouTube habe ich
gelesen was erwarten wir von jungen
Menschen denen wir die ganze Zeit
erzählen du gehörst nicht dazu würden
sie da das auch so sehen dass das auch
echt ein großes Problem ist
absolut ja und ich kann sagen wir
erwarten zu viel ja wer erwarten auf
jeden Fall zu viel und das kann von
diesen jungen Menschen unmöglich
erreicht werden und dementsprechend
äußert sich das halt auch in Unmut und
dann knallt halt auch mal ne und
Silvester ist ein würde ich sagen ganz
guter Treffpunkt ums knallen zu lassen
das haben wir dieses Mal gesehen und
natürlich ist es ähm too much gewesen
und in jeglicher Art zu zu besprechen
und auch für mich persönlich zu viel
gewesen aber es ist trotzdem wichtig
dass wir sehen was für ein Ausdruck
diese Jugendlichen außen tragen ne die
Form dessen wie gesagt muss ich
kritisieren aber wenn wir die Zeichen
nicht sehen dann glaube ich stellen wir
uns blinde als wir sind
als Sozialarbeiter kümmern Sie sich also
um Jugendliche den die Gesellschaft ja
keine faire Chance gibt im Zweifel wie
sieht denn ihre Arbeit konkret aus
ja ich bin seit fünf Jahren
Sozialarbeiter in Berlin und wir
unterstützen junge Menschen also
Jugendliche und junge Erwachsene in der
Berufsfindung und all dem was dem im
Wege steht dass ich arbeite aktuell in
einem Projekt bei outreach und ähm ja
uns gibt es seit 30 Jahren und wir
beschäftigen uns tagtäglich mit jungen
Menschen und ob die
Migrationshintergrund haben oder nicht
später war ja auch keine Rolle und ja
den widmen wir uns mit vollem Herz und
voller Leidenschaft wie gesagt seit 30
Jahren und wachsen dementsprechend merkt
man dass der Bedarf auch wächst ja und
ja es ist ein Job den man glaube ich
auch auf die Dauer nur machen kann wenn
man das ja für richtig und wichtig hält
jetzt hat sich hier bei uns ein User
Norbert Kranz mit einer Vermutung und
eben auch eine Frage an Sie geäußert er
fragt sich was macht man mit den
Menschen die integrationsunwillig sind
denken dieses Klientel sind das größte
Problem ist seine Vermutung
ja was bedeutet
integrationsunwillig ne manchmal
scheiterts ja auch einfach an der
falschen Sprache oder manchmal scheitert
einfach an der Kommunikation
grundsätzlich also wir erleben selten
integrationsunwillige Jugendliche also
das Wort finde ich sehr sehr schwierig
und es gibt ja
so viele positive Beispiele von
Integration ich meine wir haben vor
Jahren schon über Integration gesprochen
nee immer wieder ist das Thema kommt das
Thema hoch und ich bezweifle dass es
Menschen gibt die sich nicht integrieren
wollen ich glaube wenn dann gibt es
Menschen die es versuchen und schaffen
scheitern und merken ey so wie die sich
integrieren wollen oder können reicht
das einfach nicht und werden abgelehnt
und da sind andere Faktoren im Spiel das
Menschen sich nicht integrieren wollen
ja was haben Sie von dieser nicht
Integration ja legen sich ja selber
Steine in den Weg und ja das besprechen
wir natürlich auch
jetzt hat er sich kurz nach Silvester im
Spiegel Neuköllns
Integrationsbeauftragte kühnerbalci
geäußert sie sprach von jetzt den
Randalierern dort es handele sich dabei
sie kennen die Menschen wohl um Zitat
hoffnungslos abgehängte absolute User
das sind harte Worte wie sehen Sie das
also ich würde nicht mal über Menschen
so sprechen die ich nicht kenne deswegen
ist es noch größer zu kritisieren weil
sie sie kennt und ja das den Tonfall
finde ich scharf zu kritisieren wie
gesagt das finde in so einem Kontext und
in so einer Position sollte man doch
andere Worte wählen und auch
grundsätzlich nicht über Menschen so
sprechen ja auch nicht in Öffentlichkeit
es gibt noch mehr Kommentare ich schaue
kurz rein zum einen schreibt hier bei
YouTube jemand man stellt also fest
sowohl deutsche als auch Migranten die
in diesem Viertel wohnen werden zusammen
auffällig ob es wohl ein Strukturproblem
der Stadt sein könnte sie arbeiten in
dieser Stadt in Berlin wie würden Sie
darauf antworten
naja es ist kein individuelles Problem
ne also es ist nicht der Jugendliche der
ein Problem hat und aufgrund dieses
Problems reagiert das sind individuelle
Menschen und individuelle Biografien es
sind aber keine individuellen Probleme
ne Wohnungslosigkeit mangelnde Chancen
ähm Kommunikation die nicht stattfindet
wir gegen die die gegen uns das ist ja
kein individuelles Problem und deswegen
hat das genießt das natürlich auch
irgendwo eine Struktur genießen ist in
dem Kontext gleich ein falsches Wort
aber ich denke es schon dass es ein
ganzheitliches Problem ist wenn man sich
annehmen muss und nicht das Problem des
Einzelnen ne
wir wollen aber natürlich auch ganz
deutlich machen es war eben natürlich
nicht nur oder es ist nicht nur ein
Berliner Problem oder es gab nicht nur
Ausschreitungen in Berlin auch in
Stuttgart gab es 2020 beispielsweise
mehrere heftige Ausschreitungen wir
hatten am Anfang der Sendung schon mal
Bilder gesehen könnten die auch jetzt
zeigen wo möglich aber deswegen es ist
natürlich also nicht nur ein Berliner
Problem wir haben auch gerade in
Stuttgart wo es zumindest jetzt an
Silvester nicht gänzlich ruhig war aber
ruhiger haben wir mit einer
Sozialarbeiterin auch gesprochen mit
Katrin Meyer wir hören mal kurz zusammen
rein
wir sind hier auf einem sehr guten Weg
wir sind eng im Gespräch miteinander mit
allen Menschen die da in der Innenstadt
tätig sind und die ersten Erfahrungen
zeigen dass es einfach Zeit braucht Zeit
braucht um in Kontakt zu kommen mit den
jungen Menschen um alle wichtigen
Akteure an einen Tisch zu bringen und
dann dementsprechend die Ideen zu
entwickeln und auch immer wieder
nachzusteuern wenn neue Wünsche und
Bedarfe aufkommen und auch wenn sich
neue Situationen ergeben und auch die
jungen Menschen wurden beteiligt und
nach Ihren Wünschen und Bedarfen gefragt
so zum Beispiel in unserem Projekt
Wohnzimmer bei dem wir ein wirkliches
Wohnzimmer also Sofa Teppich Lampen
Couchtisch in den innenstadtnahen
Plätzen aufgebaut haben und die jungen
Menschen eingeladen haben neben uns
Platz zu nehmen auf dem Sofa und uns zu
erzählen was sie sich wünschen für ihre
Stuttgarter Innenstadt Stuttgart hat
sich für einen Weg zwischen in dem
Spagat zwischen Kommunikation und
ordnungsrechtlichen Maßnahmen
entschieden das heißt den jungen
Menschen einmal zu vermitteln ihr gehört
hierher und ihr seid uns wichtig aber
auch klar zu machen es gibt bestimmte
rote Linien es gibt bestimmte Grenzen
die gewahrt werden müssen
also in Stuttgart ist man der Meinung
dass man da eben auf einem guten Weg ist
was wäre ihre Vision für Berlin
also ich finde vorab das Projekt welches
mir neues interessant auch die Idee
einfach die Menschen einzuladen ist
grundsätzlich natürlich immer gut und
den Dialog zu suchen im Zuge der
Gentrifizierung in Berlin das ist
natürlich schwierig ne wir vertreiben
die Menschen ja oder wir werden ja und
ich sag bewusst wir weil das betrifft
uns alle an die an die Stadtgrenzen
gedrängt weil man sich die Mieten nicht
mehr leisten kann und das ist halt ein
Problem was uns alle betrifft und dem
das würde halt vielleicht so ein Projekt
so ein bisschen im Wege stehen deswegen
finde ich den Ansatz super zu sagen hey
wir geben euch den Raum und das ist ja
auch ein Thema was Jugendliche
alltäglich beschäftigt ne wir nehmen ja
die Räume ein wo sollen diese jungen
Menschen sein das heißt sie leben
eingefärbt auf engem Raum ob das zu
Hause ist oder im Stadtteil spielt gar
keine Rolle und dann
äußert sich das halt auch mal so neue
Ansätze reinzubringen und neue Ideen
durchzuführen funktioniert nicht im
Alleingang deswegen braucht man auch bei
solch kreativen Anstößen immer die
Unterstützung von Gesellschaft von Staat
von Stadt auch von Politik wo ich auch
ähnlich wie der Herr Richter vorhin auch
eine gewisse Frustration spüre und auch
ein gewisses sich alleine fühlen und das
geht nicht nur mir so sondern
grundsätzlich auch diesen jungen
Menschen natürlich
hier gibt es einen Vorschlag von Tyrell
der schreibt bei Youtube Lösungen sind
Bildungsmöglichkeiten Pflege der Kultur
und der Sprache Unterstützung von Seiten
der Gemeinschaft und der Regierung
Bekämpfen von Vorurteilen und
Diskriminierung was sollte denn ihrer
Meinung nach Politik und Gesellschaft
tun
erstmal würde ich sehr gerne die
Aufmerksamkeit auf das Thema gelenkt
haben ohne dass irgendwas explodieren
muss ja ich sag das jetzt mal ganz flott
ich finde auch runde Tische interessant
und gut aber auch wenn dann auch allein
geladen werden ne und ob das jetzt
reicht
Akteure aus der Politik daran zu setzen
bezweiflich weil bisher nicht so viel
passiert und ich glaube einfach daran
dass wir in der sozialen Arbeit ein
gutes Beispiel leisten wenn es darum
geht Dialoge zu führen und auf kreative
Ansätze zu stoßen und die durchzuführen
aber auch wir als Experten und Experten
Menschen uns mal so betiteln darf stoßen
an unsere Grenzen wenn wir merken die
Projekte können nicht weiter finanziert
werden oder es sind nur Projekte und es
geht in keine Regelfinanzierung rüber
und die Jugendlichen sich denken heute
seid ihr da morgen seid ihr weg und was
was ist das für was ist das für ein
Zeichen und ähm das wäre schon mal ein
Ansatz ne das war quasi sich überlegt
die Menschen zu einem Dialog einzuladen
um über gemeinsame Inter auszusprechen
ist auch ein schönes Zeichen was man
mitgibt und dann eben und dann eben
klaren Tisch zu schaffen und sagen was
braucht ihr was haben wir für Ressourcen
und Stichwort Ressourcen also wie gesagt
in fünf Jahren Berlin habe ich mehr
Projekte
einstampfen sehen als aufblühen und ist
halt ein ja sehr gutes Zeichen wenn es
darum geht was nicht so gut läuft also
es müsste umgekehrt sein dazu passt die
Frage aus der Community sind Kürzung der
Sozialausgaben und schlecht
ausgestattete Jugendzentren ein Grund
für den Frust auf der Straße
mit Sicherheit also ich meine
Jugendzentren beispielsweise sind ja
Räume für Jugendliche und junge
Erwachsene nicht wahr und wir gehen
davon aus dass Menschen sich dort
entfalten können und sollen auch das
ganze natürlich pädagogisch
aufbearbeitet und mit Begleitung von
Experten und Experten von Fachpersonal
aber wenn Jugendhäuser schließen und
keine Alternativen existieren und auch
nicht erklärt wird warum diese
Jugendhäuser schließen müssen und
überhaupt keine Debatte stattfinden darf
wo sich Mensch noch einbringen können
wenn Politik geführt wird dass es von
oben nach unten geht das ist über die
Menschen hinweg diskutiert wird ne und
das finde ich halt an solch Gipfeln
immer ein bisschen schwierig die Politik
trifft sich und spricht sich über die
Menschen aus aber es kommt es findet
keine Diskussion gemeinsam statt ne und
je mehr wir über die Kids sprechen je
mehr Räume wir einnehmen je mehr
Entscheidungen wir über die Köpfe hinweg
Fällen brauchen wir uns im Anschluss
nicht wundern
das ist dann knallt es gibt hier ein
kritisches Kommentar zu unserem Gespräch
von Niklas Förster bei Youtube der
schreibt also ist wieder der deutsche
Schuld haha ey das ZDF ist einfach
lächerlich also er beschwert sich hier
über unsere Unterhaltung sieht sich hier
jetzt beschuldigt was würden sie so
jemand antworten also in dem Fall
konkret Niklas Förster Antworten
ich würde dem antworten dass er sich mal
locker machen soll ja und ähm gut wenn
er das ZDF kritisieren will sollte das
sachlich machen weiß jetzt nicht was so
lächerlich sein soll und ich
unterscheide Menschen nicht zwischen
deutschen nicht deutsch ich unterscheide
Menschen zwischen
nicht zwischen großen klein dick und
dünnen braun Geld grün weiß das ist mir
für mich persönlich egal und das kann
ich machen nachdem ich mich
ausgiebig mit Menschen beschäftigt habe
und das würde ich ihnen äh ihm empfehlen
dass Sie sich mit seinem Umfeld
beschäftigt mit Menschen beschäftigt und
statt Hass zu produzieren lieber seine
Energie in konstruktive positive Dinge
steckt und ja so wieder denke ich besser
vorankommen im Leben aber meine Aufgabe
ist es auch nicht anderen Menschen zu
sagen wie sie leben sollen also
irgendwie müssen mehr gemeinsam
durchleben ne
es gibt schon also noch einige
Kommentare hier die sich also schon auch
immer noch wieder eben kritisch dann zu
der ethnischen Herkunft äußern ich
möchte dazu noch mal folgendes von der
Berliner integrations- und
migrationsbeauftragten zitieren also sie
waren von vor einer Kriminalisierung von
Migranten und sagt der Blick sollte
nicht auf die ethnische sondern auf die
soziale Herkunft gerichtet werden wir
schätzen sie das ein mit ihrer ganzen
Erfahrung
ja der Blick sollte sowieso auf ganz
viele Sachen gerichtet werden und
wahrscheinlich wird Einblick nicht
reichen aber grundsätzlich kann man
sagen dass ich die oder kann nicht sagen
dass ich diese ethnische Debatte und das
ganze Thema rund um Integration
sehr floskelartig erlebe und teilweise
einfach auch nur
ja zu Instrument uns
instrumentalisierungszwecken sehen ne
gerade jetzt bei den Berliner Neuwahlen
finde ich es ganz spannend zu sehen wie
schnell Wahlplakate sich doch ändern und
entstehen können und ich selber
Migrationshintergrund ich fühle mich
sehr deutsche ich bin hier geboren ich
bin hier aufgewachsen und habe Schule
besucht habe studiert etc pp spreche
aber auch türkisch und ähm sie auch so
aus und will jetzt aber nicht sagen an
meinem Beispiel sieht man das diese
Menschen über die wir hier sprechen sind
integriert und integrieren sich
tagtäglich mit 100% Engagement ja und es
ist einfach ein Ding zu sagen ja du hast
dich nicht integriert weil du hast jetzt
Mist gebaut erstmal sind es Jugendliche
die bauen auf die Art und Weise
dessen ist natürlich ein Unding so aber
dann muss man das strafvoll also man
muss das eben es braucht Konsequenzen
wieder Herr Richter gesagt hat
vielleicht schneller strafverfolgen das
will ich auch gar nicht abschreiben wenn
man irgendwie drei Jahre auf dem Prozess
warten muss hat man schon wieder
vergessen worum es ging aber
grundsätzlich immer mit dieser Islam und
Ethnien Karte zu kommen deshalb
Schwachsinn ne was hat denn jetzt die
Religion oder die die kulturelle
Herkunft damit zu tun meine Jugendlichen
Böller schmeißt und wenn er ihn auf dem
Polizeiauto schmeißt dann ist es ein
absolutes unbedingt zu sagen da spielt
die Ethnie eine Rolle wo ich recht geben
muss ist natürlich es gibt soziale
Strukturen die gibt es allerdings auch
nicht nur in Neukölln die wir verbessern
müssen zwingend und wir uns damit
beschäftigen müssen aber ich würde sehr
gerne wegkommen von diesem ganzen
Geschwafel und kann deswegen auch die
Argumentation des Herrn Richters auch
verstehen der unterstützt mich an dieser
These das ist Einzelfälle sind und dass
die natürlich auch irgendwo ihre
Konsequenzen kriegen aber das zu
verallgemeinern finde ich halt immer
sehr einfach und halt auch populistisch
sagt Sozialarbeiter Burak tschanne Perk
vielen Dank dass Sie sich so viel Zeit
genommen haben heute Abend und für das
Gespräch
gerne ich habe zu danken vielen Dank
und viele Kommentare von euch zum
Schluss damit wollen wir enden möchte
ich noch ein paar hier aufgreifen ohmi
schreibt bei Youtube viele äußern hier
Hass statt Lösungen gegen das Problem
und spricht damit natürlich auch etwas
an was wir übrigens in unseren
Kommentarspalten nicht haben möchten
hast und Hetze sondern gerne eine
konstruktive Diskussion die bitte darum
für heute für auch jedes nächste Mal
weitere spannende Kommentare von
Miri er schreibt oder sie er wir sind
dankbar in Deutschland leben zu dürfen
so haben meine Eltern uns aufgezogen in
unseren Ländern hätten wir nicht so ein
unbeschwertes Leben und Möhren 1994
schreibt der Staat sollte von Anfang an
klar machen dass Integration von beiden
Seiten gewollt sein muss zudem muss das
Problem mal beim Namen genannt und nicht
tabuisiert werden und schließen möchte
ich mit folgendem Kommentar ich glaube
wir sind jetzt auch schon echt 40
Minuten am Sprechen von ex-ex er
schreibt mir ist in dem öffentlichen
Diskurs bezüglich war bzw bezüglich der
Silvester Ausschreitung wichtig dass
ausdrücklich Abstand davon angenommen
wird diese Taten einer ethnischen
beziehungsweise religiösen Gruppe
zuzuordnen danke schreibt er oder sie
danke sag auch ich an eure
Aufmerksamkeit an euch für die vielen
Fragen und bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]